I'm going to talk a little bit about novel hepcidin modulators in polycythemia vera.
This is an area of a lot of excitement in MPN.
So let's get started.
All right.
Unlike in myelofibrosis, hepcidin levels are actually decreased in PV.
And this is a result of the expanded erythropoiesis that occurs in PV to support the production
of red blood cells due to constitutive JAK stat signaling, and also iatrogenically through
therapeutic phlebotomy.
So hepcidin levels are decreased, which means that you have increased iron absorption and
increased iron release from...
macrophages that are basically being funneled into the bone marrow to support the development
of new red blood cells.
So in untreated PV, you'll have low hepcidin levels.
And then with hepcidin memetics, the goal is to really increase hepcidin levels, and
that actually promotes normalization of the hematocrit.
So hepcidin memetics like resveratide and also inhibitors...
So these inhibitors of TMPRSS6 promote degradation of ferroportin, which is the only iron exporter
in cells.
And so TMPRSS6 is a protease on the cell surface that inhibits BMP and SMAD signaling and is
a negative regulator of hepcidin production in hepatocytes.
And so when you inhibit a negative regulator of hepcidin, you actually inhibit the production
of hepatocytes.
And so when you inhibit a negative regulator of hepcidin, you actually increase hepcidin
levels.
And then, of course, hepcidin and hepcidin memetics bind to and degrade ferroportin directly,
which is, like I mentioned, an iron export protein.
Increasing hepcidin levels leads to decreased dietary iron absorption, reduced iron release
from macrophages, and ultimately the goal, which is reduced erythropoiesis and restoration
of iron homeostasis in PV.
So there are a lot of...
And then, of course, there are a lot of...
Thank you.